[Applause]
for this edition of cookbook club i was
lucky enough to get to work with someone
right now who is an incredible chef but
also an incredible human
i became aware of bruno on the cbs
evening news
his story spoke to me so much and i have
been a super fan of his ever since
joining us from his restaurant in
anaheim california
please welcome chef bruno cerato
are you going to be my sea chef today
yes bruno i would
love to be your sous chef today will you
please teach me how to make inspired by
your mother right this pasta
yes caterina's pasta remember she has
the seven kids to feed every day
that made the best because we were very
poor was cooked pasta
every single day all seven love it
obviously i was the cutest one of the
seven don't tell my brother and sister
because they don't believe it
but that's what my best pasta let me get
your pan ready you put some olive oil on
it
my pan is hot and ready to go bruno okay
put some olive oil on it
all right how much do you think about a
tablespoon
yeah that's what you do i think it's
more than enough put your onion in it
good girl good girl give you a raise
i i like to play in the kitchen
see my start to get a little bit
translucent a little bit brown on the
side
yes yes yes yes yes and now
i put on my tomato first
okay you can put your kale too carrots
in
and add away the broccoli
broccoli in
thank you it's very colorful make sure
you get your
marinara sauce inside you get that you
have a jar next to you
i have it right here bruno is it okay if
i get it all over the place
you can because it's never never bad
never bad it's always good
you want to put them in the blender i'll
show you later because there's a reason
behind that you know because
we have a major problem when we saw
pasta
with full of green inside kids are kids
i don't like the green stuff
i mean i found a trick to get grandma
and mom
to feed vegetables to the kids okay
bruno i am going to make this for my
girls as
soon as we're done with this now bruno
you brought a cookbook for cookbook club
will you share your cookbook please
oh i made the cookbook for one of the
best chef in the world that's called
massimo batura
that's is it right this gold
he has a 50 shepherd working with him he
used waste food
to make fine food but he also feed
people in need from homeless to
low-income people
and we have a lot of recipes that are
easy to do at home they are not
a three-star recipe that you don't know
what to do you got to love everything he
does
and somebody who's feeding thousands of
people is always a legend
so he's like you he's an incredible
person and this is a cookbook with
highly elevated rewarded chefs but
that's not too intimidating to cook with
the next time you come to my restaurant
we cook together in the kitchen
and we go to feed the children together
i would love to
as soon as i can come to anaheim i would
love
to be in your kitchen i would love to go
with you will
even sing for you pasta italian song
what more do we need excellent bruno our
pasta is cooked the sauce is ready
to go bruno what's next put it in the
blender because we need to blend i got a
kiss will not see the green stuff
oh god it's going everywhere bruno okay
basil in top perfect on
oh go on i'm on already
oh my god i'm going to hire you for sure
as my sous chef
you're doing phenomenal job do i put it
on the pasta
yeah put enough to mix it because
i see you doing fantastic that's it is
enough mr
mix of the wow that is a tangle
okay girl big little bad as soon you
finish to mix the robot put some
all right you ready to do a beauty shot
bruno
i am looking here
[Applause]
wait can i try it now bruno is exactly
what i'm waiting for we got my fork on
me
[Music]
viva pasta
so good but make sure you make that for
your girls tonight okay
i absolutely will because you've hidden
all these delicious veggies in there
it's so wonderful bruno you're so
amazing
i'm so honored to have met you and
everybody who's watching please go to
our website for the full recipe
and information on bruno's charity
katarina's club named after his mother
[Music]
you